okay [ __ ] your boy is sucking back
it's like a pile of [ __ ]
Wow okay what a great time to be a lot
and very cunning okay yes yeah I'm even
world where I said lest I get cut and
where am I supposed to go let's just go
up there how do I get up there there for
it I'll go through somehow these are the
grab lift there's a lot of [ __ ] going on
here what's up where's the graph left
wasn't running I know okay and anyways
how's everyone's days on today you know
I'm doing great it's that's Moritz honey
like you can't apply a girl I can't comp
I am these days I strike a little faster
cause I know I've been like a little
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't even know if I'm gonna make
this one come on Kenny of course I am
okay sailor here I got my ranch that's
how I roll a night control towers up
above and I written in this race boot
get with it okay
operator deployment resuming
construction detective please clear
aperture of the brief
absolutely [ __ ] not what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] back there where's the UM to have
any health kits now I am so [ __ ] right
now oh [ __ ] my [ __ ] in here that's right
I love this looking at the window I love
to see a live specimen required for
scanning because it just means I'm doing
my job right I know okay again a lot on
I'm set
calm down I got area hacking six hit it
I'm a hacker now Oh [ __ ] windows
control are done wait wouldn't say about
windows okay so liver thing hepatic
[ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] hacker y'all
[ __ ] ain't playing with me I
mess with the past i Rizzo ass
[ __ ] okay I see how [ __ ]
[ __ ] my dick is oozing a lot of [ __ ]
here on people outside today
like don't you guys have anything better
to do than be outside and I oh [ __ ]
that's where I gotta go
okay I got a lot of [ __ ] don't have like
Norma's out the ass engineer is six
stamina will build a [ __ ] I should get
that
okay I got to make it across your wings
you feel you should watch this real
quick
again I think yeah so [ __ ] ominous
music playing was getting okay
you see if I could shoot a glue gun just
to make it a little farther [ __ ] ah
let's get a little tired of hacking I
gotta be honest get a little tired when
someone said this seems too easy I was
like a putt just [ __ ] dick off
I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] here nice ah okay
there's a weapon upgrade gets just
[ __ ] saw it exists now I called it gun
and then a suit hit spare parts system
star parts
six feet
[Music]
and that
now this is really a good game like this
is actually like a really good game
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't just jump
right
I'll [ __ ] check all this show that's
for sure
oh you haven't tomatoes huh I they call
mated it to either like I just literally
I sneak my way on two places and I just
eat all their [ __ ] like if I get on to
your place you better hope that your
[ __ ] locked up can i disrupt this
command at all this is William you
acting chairman of the trans our Board
of Directors they will leave your
credentials to authorize this mission of
course my authentication sign is a de
Invictus Emperor Title II signed checks
out
good morning director you shuttle is
hots and holding orbits awaiting mission
parameters
you must secure every piece of COBOL
clearance level technology and research
aboard Talos 1 then eliminate all
transfer personnel all personnel yes no
survivors it's your show there you know
payment will be deposited into six
separate Benelux accounts after you
transmit evidence of success as if my
operator feeds on just keep watching
we strongly advise deploying your
technical officer to a station router
inside the firewalls first ideal site
would be in the hardware labs yes I've
seen the schematics mister you good bye
sure will destroy the transmission up in
the hardware labs okay
so it's over there the Fox outside fine
grant luck what I don't think I ever did
his body's just like orbiting
they clean up this [ __ ] look Wow what
the [ __ ] why they hurt me this is going
to suck dick if I remember this place
[ __ ] sucks dick hardware labs oh [ __ ]
I just gone through the outside my
off-site personal they are experienced
in the trends now books is through I do
solve people problems your work mates
hiding in the cargo bay are going to
suffocate in a few minutes maybe you can
save them but you'll have to come off
the walls life support
you [ __ ] dead
from here and none of the doors are
responding atmosphere controls are in
life-support if you can help do it quick
or this is the last time we'll be
talking mr. Lazar is right to be alarmed
though her assessment is mistaken doll
is manipulating the oxygen and nitrogen
mixture with nitrogen flooding into the
atmosphere
anyone in the cargo bay will asphyxiate
far more quickly than any simply cut the
oxygen I suspect they'd already be dead
if tall weren't trying to use them to
manipulate you let me see something
because if I can access the hardware
labs from outside there's an airlock
then I'm [ __ ] just gonna load them
I'm just going to [ __ ] them go outside
and I just can't get through there
come on
obstruction detective please clear
aperture of the brief okay so let me
just go this way
[Music]
so there tell you guys probably want to
kill me what the [ __ ] is this oh it's
like shipping and receiving okay I'm
pretty sure a grand lock what's floating
in space still I don't know I'll check I
think I tried on a [ __ ]
[Music]
microgravity detected okay do I have
grant Lockwood [ __ ] [ __ ] license
my op Solis a our experience in the
transfer books through I do solving
people problems
your mates hiding in the cargo bay I'm
going to suffocate Holly said maybe you
can save them but you'll have to come
out of the walls read life support the
clock is ticking does cut the oxygen to
the cargo bay there's nothing I can't
offer her none of the doors are
responding atmosphere controls are in
life support if you do it quick or this
is the last time we'll be talking
psychotronic [ __ ] I miss Ellis ours
right to be alarmed our assessment is
mistaken Dahl is manipulating the oxygen
and nitrogen mixture with nitrogen
flooding into the atmosphere anyone the
cargo bay will asphyxiate far more
quickly than had he simply cut the
oxygen I suspect they'd already be dead
if tall we're trying to use them to
manipulate you
we're just came out of
what is that ex-officer
hmm
ah
what is it power plant okay so according
to this map I am in a totally wrong spot
what Bible shocks critical yes [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] the tech officers up there
Michael toward my arms I hidden as an HR
expense on the transom looks through I
do some people problems your workmates
hiding in the cargo bay I'm going to
suffocate in a few minutes okay you can
finish our problems up there to come out
of the walls rat life support the
clock's ticking
check officers over there oxygen to the
cargo bay
something I can try right indoors
responding atmosphere controls are in
life support if you can help do it quick
five support life support life support
life support races [ __ ] is there an
airlock take a [ __ ] airlock in there
the last time we'll be talking
mr. Lazar is right to be alarmed though
her assessment is mistaken doll is
manipulating the oxygen and nitrogen
major with nitrogen flooding into the
atmosphere
anyone in the cargo bay will asphyxiate
far more quickly than any simply cut the
oxygen I suspect they'd already be dead
if tall weren't nice to Florida guy do
you
so come on come on open open open open
open open open open open open
I'll bet open yes [ __ ] okay okay power
plan if I remember this place with a
[ __ ] hole
you okay I have to go level of explosive
wanting nothing please be watching other
boys all culinarian awardable medical
kit couldn't handle try to relax
all done please fill out a patient
experience questionnaire so I can serve
you better next time can I ever check
this out I never did okay I got this
real quick just emails warning dangerous
level of Explorer warning dangerous
level of explosive gas detected please
evacuate and avoid all open flames or
sparks until repairs can be made ah
warning dangerous level of explosive gas
detected please evacuate I'd avoid all
over the flames or sparks until repairs
can be made
swimming like a dangerous level of
explosive golf - token thank you
get that off I can't see [ __ ] baby yeah
yeah yeah I can't think right now
chose woefully
10,000 over there octopus homes over
there
how the [ __ ] do I get up there up
[Applause]
everything is fine my support and
motivation understand your operating
levels Kaslow provision like mocha you
did it
colourings transport with a medical
operator then we can see about removing
is neuro mad and hopeful at gaining is
structurally the process was very
contained was recommended [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] does this mean
Oh chat site I support air quality ratio
below standard operating level
commissary contain Morgan the air is
flowing again I can breathe and I hope
this means dull Kent thank you a little
longer and never mind
Elessar out okay so what am I supposed
to than that I did like 20 missions
right now a tech officer cars that [ __ ]
kill him with a kill him
ah operating looks half was going to
wash recommended ha
I keep getting called